well it is mother's day this sunday and
speaking for moms everywhere
we always appreciate something special
on our special day
hector mejia is live at tivoli village
with a couple of sweet ideas that you
might like for mom
good morning hector hey there sherry
good morning and we're profiling a
couple of local businesses here as they
get ready for a big
busy weekend for mother's day so they
have a whole range of options here we're
at donata here at tivoli village here we
have a couple of candles off to the left
we have some
comfy slippers that sure look really
comfortable and what mother does not
want to be comfortable at home
joining us we have kristin owner here
all right so show us around and thank
you for having us so early in the
morning
oh thank you for coming show us a couple
of items here
well we have beautiful bubble bath we
have also our cozy
slippers that any mother would love we
have beautiful candles
one that says mom's kitchen we have
diffusers
we do lovely wrapping to get it all
ready for the customer to give to their
moms
it's a day to cater to mom and we do it
best here at tafole village
you're a mom yourself what are you
looking forward to the most besides just
enjoying the family time and maybe
taking a day off oh
i think just relaxation is just the best
best medicine yeah price range tell us
about a couple of items here
um price range i would say we range from
we have a 20
candle we range up to i would say
100 150 depending we have something for
everybody
so it's everybody's budget we have
something here for you so as you chat
with customers you know what are we
hearing from them after you know a lot
of families had a really
different and rough year a lot of
families looking to make it special
extra special for mom this year i think
it's so nice to make it extra special
for my moms are so special and we love
to cater to
the mom here that's what we do every day
it's a go-to for gifts
and we love to just make it easy for
the customer um just to give
and you have a lot of cool ideas we have
soaps we have
the slivers we just showed and you have
a lot of different colors too
and once you walk in here you really get
a punch of a
beautiful scent of aromatherapy yes we
just love
our scents we have soaps we have the
candles with essential oils our bubble
baths we are the scent store for sure
we also have cozy loungewear it's all
about relaxation and catering to mom
pretty much everything thank you so much
so i'm gonna
go around browse around try to find
something for my mother and speaking of
mother sherry
i think it'd be safe to say that we just
want to wish
everyone an early happy mother's day i
mean i know it's friday but we're just
days away from this big day for a lot of
moms out there
oh that's your mom hector mrs mejia
what was that that's your we are looking
at a picture of your mom
she's a picture of my mom thank you
while we're at i just want to wish my
mom a happy mother's day felizia lost
mother's mom
i love you thank you for giving me life
and
i'll see you soon thank you mom you're
going to make us cry
oh that's so sweet i'm already emotional
myself yes
oh my goodness your mom is beautiful um
can i make one suggestion for the store
owner there on those candles the ones
that say mom's kitchen
can she re-label those somebody else's
kitchen
for a day
for a day you know what let's say for a
whole month okay all right
that works too